oh [__]
[Music]
what the [__] can I say I'm saying it's
a beautiful day to be alive you got the
world by the balls the sun shining the
birds are chirping you got [__]
reefer who gives a [__] about exams
you're gonna sit down worry about [__]
who the [__] is better than you that's
the question of the [__] day who's
battling you've nobody nobody got the
world by the balls
you got three four hours in the bank and
that's all you need oh you need
facilitate tuesday october 25th it's a
big set of [__] balls a knife reefer
and some water
that's all you don't even need money
today you're running on [__] energy
and sound but joey enough is enough
smoke that [__] reefer jaii get the
[__] off the airwaves all right
with smoke and a beautiful reaper
tonight I got some [__] boo cookies I
got some [__] perennial old G
and we got the end of the [__] brain
freeze and this damn man so I'm rolling
today [__] good I ain't got time
to [__] around all right
look at this [__] we're going deep in
the murky waters of the [__] on the
world whether you like it I don't give a
[__] what you like it's what uncle Joey
my city there you go did some out of my
comfort zone last night went to a
nighttime jiu-jitsu class over at
[__] legacy I'm sore than ever but I
don't give a [__] jack I got the heart
of a [__] lion I'm still taking a fat
[__] 53 a fungi toenail I don't give a
[__] you want to stop me then I get a
[__] rhinoceros that knocked me over
[__] the weakest said I got two
back big [__] bags of stars you know
we're going to Vegas Friday Larry's
there Steve's the mom's coming with me
talking landfill effect he's having a
kid's birthday party we're gonna crash
in his [__] clowns and who's better
than you let that listen that's the
question of the day today who the [__]
is better than you but I got time for
[__] answers I'm too busy sparking
I love this part of the day we get to
smoke a little reefer together and
chitchat about the day I had you did
you're bold you did your twenty two
push-ups you think you set up shot of
fruit smoothie what else you want from
me okay let's finish up this [__]
brain free so we could sprinkle that
[__] right on top and spark this deep
you know what I wish somebody paid me to
smoke reefer every day like eight to
four half-hour
I just keep smoking - you had blossom
that'd be my [__] eye deal job couple
benefits some dental who's better than
you nobody I've been telling you that
since I [__] a Mac if you don't
believe me you won't listen to society
and your family and what everybody basis
you want [__] these [__] you
think if I were to listen to them I
would have still been here with you
[__] I would have shot myself when I
was 20 [__] - but I didn't give a
[__]
it's a Jew holiday every day
you gotta get out of house I get that
[__] envelope Gentiles there's a
Gentile somewhere waiting with an
envelope to just hand over to you
sitting there playing [__] ps2 games
without a [__] of his are you little
[__] affronts get out there
[__] go get a ham put some boards
up do something doctor police breathing
it's that reefer [__] flowing in your
lungs I can feel it all the way up to my
[__] brain it's about this snap we
had a big day today [__] I
gotta go talk to people to meetings I
was gonna go to acupuncture but Obama's
and [__] town on my tracks is gonna
be all [__] up so I had to postpone
that till Thursday but besides that I
met the [__] Dark Horse saloon
tonight with my man D'Agostino do a
couple minutes the first time on stage I
shot this special and struck him [__]
scratched because I plan on she's
another [__] special next November so
uh that's my [__] point for the day
right [__] still my god you did to
her at a couple other things then
Thursday we had to viva [__]
Las Vegas you understand me
the South Point casino what do you got
me talking for you know I'm talking
forever I might that guy with the joint
I want to tell you a long [__] story
yeah Bab that guy he's got to join this
and his burnin it must taste right but
it's [__] kid listen I'll give a [__]
about the kid spark that [__] joint
outsider that's the school somewhere
let's do some blue could be anything
little blue cookies and then I'll let
you in your [__] merry way you'd go
back and hang with your buddies and
drink coffee whatever the [__] you do
drink coffee I drink gasoline from
7-eleven understand [__] blue cookies
the [__] blue topaz damn is
this [__] thank you Bernie Sanders when
they told him it was over he said Bernie
it's [__] over go call me and smoke
some of this you'll be fine
stay outside you got it [__] let the
general public look he [__] ice face
did you see him he was sitting that
stormed the bull cook he says the [__]
that Bernie Sanders smoke
oh just nothing totally amazing I love
this time of the day I get to chitchat
with you [__] we'd get to
settle a blueprint for the day which
means you know the blueprint of the day
is a sling dick whatever you need to do
with your [__] lucky day [__] up
today's your day you've been waiting for
the ship to come in this [__] [__]
came and you want to sit there feel
sorry for yourself get up your [__]
salute the flag wash your balls [__]
bidet [__] do whatever the [__] you
need to do you gotta get out there times
moving [__] quick who gives a [__]
the only person who could judge you it's
a [__] marine or Jesus Christ himself
and I ain't seen these [__] in
weeks so do me a favor smoked a ball
wash your [__] and get out there
[__] it's a beautiful [__] day
to be alive and with that I gotta take
two steps to the rear and get out of
here all right I love you [__]
Friday Saturday South Pointe casino
November 11th Boston will be [__]
Peter the 12th at Foxwoods casino in
Connecticut stop flopping around I see
you can't stop his late I'm scum to the
gills dismay you do to me [__]
who loves you it's Tuesday they didn't
come I'm at that I'll be knowing byah